all right here we go am I talking the
table is a guy in Southern California
who's made it his job to surprise people
with random acts of kindness and they
really go viral so his name's Isaiah
Garza right now the man behind the
camera is him and he's walking up
talking to a 97 year old World War II
veteran he asks him hey I got an extra
ticket to go to Disneyland you want to
go with me and the man's like me you
want to take me to Disneyland sure he
couldn't believe someone would want to
take him it's a magical experience was
posted on Tick Tock in a 51 second video
that's got check it out 17 million views
now here's the thing we were actually
working on a story about Isaiah Garza
right around the time he posted that
we've been working on the story for
several weeks because we wanted to find
out who is this guy and what drives him
to help other people like he does
I'm also going to give you five hundred
dollars
no no
no
no
[Music]
of course
if you were to just scroll through
Isaiah Garza's social media account you
would get what feels like a lesson in
random acts of kindness why
[Music]
oh
thank you sir this is one of the best
days of my life away every day Garza
lends a helping hand to strangers and a
lot of them are homeless I got you a
brand new cell phone Suite
[Music]
bones food clothes money anything that
might brighten their day to build an
actual connection
and a heartfelt love for a human being
it makes me feel really good and
sometimes he gives them what they need
most I raised you guys twenty five
thousand dollars
you guys are getting a home you guys are
no longer homeless I got kind of like
obsessed with seeing people happy and
seeing the reactions on people's faces
who like maybe live on the streets or
struggling you know because I myself as
someone
struggled for so long Garza grew up in
Washington state his parents immigrated
from Mexico and he says life from the
very beginning was not easy at one point
we you know we got our house taken from
us and we had no money and we had to
sell everything and we were living
paycheck's paycheck and just that I was
like I'm gonna find a way to get out of
here and I'm going to save the day he
eventually got a scholarship to Fashion
school in Los Angeles but for almost a
year he lived on the streets of downtown
L.A coming back here it's just like
facing your demon
just uh it was tough that it was tough
at that time maybe that's why you are so
comfortable
um
absolutely you know absolutely yeah I
sell those people all the time yeah it's
almost like a comfort level those tough
years didn't break him he'll tell you it
made him a better person and enabled him
to do what he does today so selflessly
if I didn't become homeless and struggle
and suffer I would have never have done
what I'm doing today it would never have
happened that way there's no chance
there's no chance because it just gave
me so much you know of what
I shouldn't drive maybe
some weird energy that I can't you know
that maybe suffering gives you I'm gonna
go to the store right now I wanted to
see if you needed anything
I'm dead seriously he turned that
suffering into a business as a
well-renowned celebrity loved jewelry
designer I actually became my own
publicist and started contacting their
managers and stylists myself and I would
just tell them like hey my name is
Isaiah Garza you know I grew up homeless
and I you know I've experienced
homelessness and this is my story and
people were crazy enough to say yes but
I love that you didn't try and
whitewashed the story sure you didn't
try and sugarcoat it you like leaned
into your homelessness I leaned into it
because that's what makes like my story
special in a way Isaiah Garza has
garnered close to 10 million followers
on social media he secured deals with
Brands like KFC he's raised money
through GoFundMe and in some cases he
uses his own money to give back how do
you make sure that when you go out and
shoot that video you don't come off like
a used car salesman there's always going
to be people that are going to be
skeptical no matter what you do I think
I know inside of my heart and soul that
I'm coming from an angle of love and
as long as you approach things with love
that's all that matters I
on the day that we were with him he
rented an ice cream truck handing out
free ice cream to people who were
homeless on Skid Row in downtown L.A
we're on the light sometimes but he's a
light sometime without him splashing his
light we'll get lost in that dark he
told us that he hopes to build lifelong
connections and even friendships with
people like the Gerardo family I forgot
my wallet today okay and I wanted to see
if he'd be able to like possibly buy my
lunch for me so he surprised the family
by first asking them to give him money
how did you feel about being asked by a
stranger for money well that was
surprised and then all right It's Only
Money I could earn that one again as
long as it helps you
feel better and that's when Garza turned
the tables I would love to buy you and
your family's Christmas presents I'm
gonna give you guys 500 wow so for
Christmas man
it turns out the gerardos had just moved
to America and they were struggling
financially and emotionally their
daughter Sophia has cerebral palsy
[Music]
since December Garza has helped to raise
over thirty six thousand dollars for the
family what would you want people
watching this story to know about
Isaiah and his idea it's like he's
[Applause]
Michelle said from
[Applause]
[Music]
him
five dollars I'm actually gonna give you
five hundred dollars
[Music]
what do you get from these videos I mean
life
and love
it's like a really generic answer but
that's what it is what are you hoping to
do next my goal is ultimately to become
one of the greatest philanthropists of
my generation I want to build schools in
third world countries and I want to
build my own shelter someday or shelters
I think that I was born to do this and
when you're born to do something you're
going to do it until like the wheels
fall off
Garza told me he does not get paid by
Tick Tock or any social media platform
but through his posts he has been able
to secure sponsorship deals like the one
he had with KFC Kentucky Fried Chicken
and other brands sometimes he'll have
the family he surprises start a GoFundMe
account yeah so the money can be given
to them that way but I like what he said
that he's obsessed with seeing people
happy yeah you can tell that it comes
from a very pure place with him yeah he
called it an addiction an addiction to
see people and light up with spontaneous
Joy addiction to do good yeah we all
could do that ain't that a good thing
yeah yeah Davis too early to have me
crying like this man come on now man
that was good y'all should have seen
Gail in the piece she said David what
happened how does he get paid I said
it's in the tag and David said just wait
for the tag and then this one over here
said I don't want to go to a movie with
you you talk through the whole movie am
I right or am I wrong
I have a couple of things to say smarty
pants
great job David thanks brother